so you know Elon he rolled out the new  color verification and uh if you pull  this up we got the Washington Post they  get a yellow badge and they say that you  oh yellow means business and I'm like I  I could not but notice that all of the  news outlets are yellow  is that a is that was that on purpose is  Elon Musk behind the scenes laughing and  mocking them yellow journalism it's a  reference to just garbage you know  garbage in yellow bellies uh stocks and  Hammer had a very interesting tweet  highlighting the which one  no no no he he said that this is the  universal symbol for propaganda and  sensationalism and well he's not wrong  but the post-millennial I think is  yellow yeah and uh it's just you know I  don't think it they just made news  organizations yellow I just think that's  funny it's like wink wink nudge nudge